The Exorcist believer is a new take on
the 1973 classic that has major
potential for two killer sequels it
stays grounded in the original narrative
with Ellen Buren's return as Chris
mcneel it pulls from actual stories of
real life possession and keeps the
audience on their toes with some
gut-wrenching horror that even had the
director's skin crawling there's already
a high bar attached to this movie
because the 1973 film made such an
impact on pop culture in General but
this blumhouse movie is the most
expensive one they're making yet Jason
Blum and his production company signed
on with universal for a $400 million
deal the money Skyler where is the rest
that entails two potential sequels he
says this is the riskiest movie of his
entire career he shares a bit about his
anxiety in his interview with sci-fi